I
you're watching swype coming up on this
week's show the smart buttons that could
make life easier for people with sight
problems South London to Silicon Valley
I meet the British tech prodigy making
his mark with six and prepare for an
invasion in our games freezing hello and
welcome to swipe we love it when we get
to talk about tech making life easier
and this week we've been finding out
about some Bluetooth buttons designed
for visually impaired people to help
them around the house his will to
explain five-year-old Lenny lost his
sight when he was just 10 months old
after a tumor damaged his optic nerves
and one of the things he finds difficult
is getting around his home but these big
buttons called pips have helped him to
feel more confident once Lenny here's
the beeps he heads in that direction and
presses the button this turns the sound
off and activates the next one in the
sequence the buttons are connected via
bluetooth and can be easily customized I
had thought well it's only a little
beeping thing you know it's not going to
be that fascinating for him but it's the
the level of control that he has
actually doesn't matter what the what
the stimulus is it was just enough for
him to how this is my game and I know
what I'm doing and I can I can take
control of the whole process the pips
were originally created for people
living with dementia to help them
through their daily routines so you
might put one by the bed to wake you up
or another on a chest of drawers to
remind you to get dressed the code and
instructions for how to build pips are
now free to download and the inventors
keen for people to get creative with it
you've got to be pretty handy with a
soldering iron and you've got to know
your way around writing a little bit of
code but we think that that should be
accessible to a lot of students a lot of
research organizations people who are
who are really well placed to to try and
run trials with vulnerable people there
are around 35,000 blind and partially
sighted children and young people in the
UK
so how much of an impact could something
like this have on their lives it could
be put in schools it could help slightly
older children then Lenny discover new
routes within an environment it has many
many different applications in
understanding different rooms within a
house or within a school at the moment
the pips are just prototypes but if they
get picked up by other researchers life
for people like Lenny could start to get
easier you choose which one you pressing
it can start believing will sergeant Sky
News stay with us still to come I'll be
sitting down with a silicon valley-based
Londoner who's using tech to help us all
get a good night's sleep that's coming
up after a round up of some of this
week's other tech news the uk's tech
scene has been reacting to that
monumental news you want to fail to
notice the EU referendum results we know
the effects won't be known for years but
initial fears within the startup
community have been based around the
size at the future talent pool and
worries that investors might choose to
put funds into other European startup
hubs instead the google-owned robot
builder Boston Dynamics has been working
on a smaller version of one of its BOTS
the spot mini weighs fifty five pounds
is all electric and one of the company's
quietest creations it can run for about
90 minutes enough time to get a good
amount of housework done in that case a
smart cycle helmet that detects body
movement has smashed its funding target
on a crowdfunding site class on can
detect vehicles in your blind spot and
it activates turn and brake signals
based on what your body's doing the team
behind it we're only looking for thirty
thousand dollars but at the time of
putting this week's white together
they've already raced past the 60,000
mark and while you're on your bike maybe
this project to make navigation easier
could come in handy it's a sat-nav in a
bicycle Bell that apparently finds the
safest routes for you to take and
remembers where you left your bike the
European Space Agency is helping to
develop
Lou Belle its creators are raising money
via crowdfunding to be able to
manufacture their first batch stick
around for our games preview we journey
into space to explore strange new worlds
but first the term texture gets banded
around quite a bit doesn't it we tend to
think of people like Facebook founder
Mark Zuckerberg but what about the
current crop of young fresh Silicon
Valley CEOs well one of them dropped in
solana recently where I grabbed him for
a chat not many twenty-something
londoners are running their own tech
firms in Silicon Valley James proud is
though the British entrepreneur moved to
California in 2011 set up his second
company just a year later when he was 20
and now leads a team of 50 people with
more than 28 million pounds in funding
but if you'd known him as a kid you
might have expected this kind of success
is it true that you taught yourself to
code at the age of nine it sounds a
little sad but but yes I was I loved the
internet and then I discovered that you
could actually basically build websites
for yourself and so that kept me busy
for quite a few years so then how did
you go from South London to Silicon
Valley started basically like building
websites for people when I was 12 my mum
thought I was a drug dealer I tried to
explain that drug dealers don't well
because I money suddenly getting a
little bit of money as I where's this
coming from and I said well there's
these checks and they're coming from
America and she's a look I don't want to
know don't tell me about it James chose
not to go to university when he got a
tempting offer to go elsewhere right
there she had the opportunity to move to
the valley I was basically given the
money to go out there by a guy called
Peter Thiel who was one of the founders
of PayPal but I ain't special facebook
yeah so that was a pretty easy decision
do what I'm doing now but in the best
place in the world to do it I think for
my parents it was like what he's getting
paid to do something better than sit in
his bedroom doing what he's doing now so
for them it was either the lesser a
skier option and now you're the CEO of
hello the company behind sense which is
here tell us tell us about sense so so
since is it's a sleep device for helping
you to fall asleep inside here is
basically a sound machine so it can play
sounds like white noise rainfall calming
medicines it also tracks your sleep but
not just your sleep but all of the
environmental conditions such as light
sound temperature humidity sleep
trackers are becoming more common does
it concern you that the market is
becoming overcrowded what we found is a
lot of people that start tracking their
sleep through something on their wrist
or their phone or other times they stop
doing that and actually switch over to
sense how would you respond to people
who think that sleep trackers and sleep
devices are just a bit gimmicky when you
actually look at the science behind it
everything that happens throughout our
day is impacted by our night whether
it's mental health whether its weight
all of these things poor sleep
negatively affects what do you think the
biggest difference is between here
in the UK and the US when it comes to
nurturing tech talent and startups with
big ideas you go back for decades and
there's been tech startups in the valley
it's something that's beginning to shift
here in the UK and it's wonderful to see
like I could see now really starting a
company in the UK where as a few years
ago I think it would have been much much
harder so do you think you might come
back then and start a new company in the
UK why there's 50 people relying on me
in San Francisco I don't think there'll
be too pleased oh yes Sarge obligations
James thank you for speaking to us thank
you we've seen loads of new video game
releases over the past few months but
now things are starting to slow down a
little bit it's just that time of year
so we thought we'd make the most of the
opportunity to show you a few games due
to be released soon Here's Lucy I've
seen things
a few things no man's sky is a game
that's got a lot of hype it's very
simple in its concept you're an explorer
in space and you know you've got your
little vehicle you've got your spaceship
you've got like a jetpack and got like a
like a scanning tool usually with video
games you know like an artist will
meticulously crap like planets and
things to go in it whereas no man's sky
is quite unique in that everything's
procedurally generated so it's made by
an algorithm if you discover a planet
you can upload its coordinates to this
thing called the Atlas which it's like
an this big online database that other
players can can look at and you can give
the coordinates to a friend and they can
meet you on a planet but it's coming out
on august 10 on ps4 and pc well the
warcraft is an incredibly famous video
game franchise it's a MMORPG so it's
massively online multiplayer and you
have these RPG elements so you can craft
a character the way you kind of want it
but now there's a brand new expansion
pack so it's World of Warcraft Legion
and if you can play in the game for a
number of years you'll probably have a
max level character which at the moment
sits at about 100 you can raise that
level now 210 so it'll be more quest a
new storyline it's a brand new area
called the broken Isles and it's brand
new class so there's the demon hunter
park people always make these stories
you know oh the numbers of subscriber
numbers are diminishing they are but
that game is still incredibly popular
and if you've still got the world of
warcraft bug then you can play Legion on
August 30th on PC and Mac
Porter horizon three good announced at
e3 and this time you know we're not in
America at a music festival anymore
we're going to Australia so that means
that on top of your big roster of meaty
supercars there's about 350 cars in this
one you'll also get some brand new
vehicles like four by fours and dune
buggies to really take advantage of the
Australian terrain it's being created by
a playground games and they've said that
there's going to be four player co-op
online it'll be a part of Xbox play
anywhere the brand new thing from
Microsoft so if you buy it digitally on
xbox one you get a copy on Windows 10
and your save transfers between two as
does your achievements that's pretty
cool it's coming out in September xbox
one and pc
that's it for this week take a good look
at Sky News on mobile tablet catch-up
sky cute and snapchat for all the latest
tech stories throughout the week and
we'll see you again next time bye-bye